okay [ __ ] okay [ __ ] I bet you're
special [ __ ] [ __ ] we're doing dragon
rising a dragon was sighted near white
one and so I kind of go get some
reinforcements yeah we're where the
where the [ __ ] am i okay yeah I was like
what's up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and that's also really [ __ ] up I I
don't know why they keep the body around
what's though [ __ ]
thank you
I Jose around here I don't know where
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] says all right the
horse is [ __ ] on I am really always I
believe my bugaboo as if I'm that you
helped set it is my horse the [ __ ]
glowing red eyes normal hey the stinking
day and oh I'm the state a convict
indicating banda Guerra sugandha alright
the Western watchtower oh [ __ ] their
fire going on
I know it just thought we figure out
what happened along something shut up
and look for survival we need to know
what okay
around the air
no get back it's still here somewhere
coffee and talk just a crap when they
tried to make a run for it and you can't
grab Kaiba he comes again
where is it
Oh
oh [ __ ] okay it looks like I'm going
[ __ ] arrow now where is ok gonna hit
it
what's up
all right as it moves so fast again a
min turn around
that bench
I'm sure damn we got him we got that
yes yes
you take these [ __ ] arrows back
what is too heavy well [ __ ] I have
what weighs like a lot track of always
[ __ ] time
and
hmm
they should get rid of some of the chef
yeah you get rid of some of this
[ __ ]
the blade of whoa
a pickaxe show no fair
what's happening
[ __ ]
I wish our this job
[ __ ] sat on me man
we check the map
ok
go around this show I guess I'm just on
around i sent by the weather effects
Creed don't doubt i actually like rain
again it's not like that other words
shut the heavens for
what was that even know what that was
wait
alright sit so far away
wow I gives me the chills of Dragon yes
sir I tell that guy
good you're finally here we all stand
waiting for so what happen at the
watchtower what's the dragon there yeah
I knew I could count on your left but
there must be more to it than that
dragonborn what do you know it too great
here really were summoning you masters
of the way the dragon book if you you
heard again what else could it mean gray
beard didn't you hear the thundering
sound as you return to whiterun that was
the voice of the grave here summoning
used to high Hrothgar hotel happening
sensor hello Sonny what that wasn't I've
accepted until the summer that he was to
tell us about Laura are so from God calm
yourself what does any of this Lord not
and let's not our friend here people in
black I don't see any time to him being
different what dragon boy nor non-tech
why you [ __ ] up ignorant these are
sacred traditions to go back to the
pounding of the First Empire Oh stronger
don't be so hard on Avenue I meant no
disrespect course it's just that one of
these great beers wants it oh that's the
gravy
not ours and am I design whatever
happens when you killed that dragon it
reveals something in you the crazier
target if they think your dragons or
Louise one you better get up to high
Hrothgar immediately and there is no
refusing to cover of the grave you I am
here you know to climb the seven
thousand steps again I need the google
flood you know that high Hrothgar is a
very peaceful very disconnected from the
Troublesome before I wonder the
Greybeards you don't know that what's
going on down they haven't seen to care
before no matter go to high hot sauce
learn what the Greybeards can peaches
you've done a great service for me in my
city dragonball by my right yar i name
you saying of white bank yes